I'm sure you've had some nightmare
experiences Frank like I had a fight
where I was fighting in uh this is my
third Pro fight on fighting in Virginia
Norfolk Virginia where it was by George
Mason University and I fly out there I
knocked the dude out and as I knocked
him out hit my thumb exploded compound
fracture exploded out and they I think
they paid me like four grand maybe three
grand two and two for that fight and
then I was like hey man I need to go to
the doctor my hands bleeding everywhere
but my dad and brother came to the show
like no let's go see the exhibits in
Washington DC like the Lincoln Memorial
and stuff so I'm walking around like
lighthead I'm like Dad I need to go to
the doctor we go to the doctor and I
they just didn't cover it so I had to
pay for I'd have health insurance at the
time I was broke and so I remember the
show didn't cover it because they just
tried to acknowledge it during the
fights they're like well how do we know
they were aware I mean it's a compound
fracture they knew what's happening yeah
they were like don't worry we'll take
care of it so I go to the doctor assume
it's covered they just never covered it
I never covered it yeah so I I remember
that fight ended up costing me like six
grand